perhaps you've seen it maybe in a dream
welcome everybody to the next episode of
Souls news it's actually been a little
while since I made one of these and
that's partly because all of the big
news right now deserves its own video
all of which are the most recent videos
on my channel so if you haven't seen
those then check them out they're there
if you didn't watch them but for now
let's open with a discussion about the
new Dark Souls 2 trailer that just aired
the other day and let's dissect it a
little bit for the small details you
might have missed if you missed the
trailer itself then click the link
on-screen it'll open in a new tab and
then come back here to hear what I have
to say so the opening shot in this
trailer actually shows a short cinematic
which almost seems like it was cut off
prematurely maybe it was a glimpse at
the prologue similar to Dark Souls in
this we can dissect some dialogue so the
narrator starts with perhaps you've seen
it maybe in a dream a murky forgotten
land a place where Souls may mend your
ailing mind the narrator is referring to
the lost kingdom of drangleic which she
describes in more detail in the next
line of dialogue but for now why are we
seeing drangleic the lost kingdom in a
dream is this a place where undead are
drawn to I reckon it is if it's a place
where Souls may mend your ailing mind
then it's going to sound like heaven to
a hollowing undead think about it
imagine you're cursed with on death
getting more and more hollow every time
you die it would be a fate worse than
death
this dialogue tells us that drangleic is
a land of promise for the undying a
place where they can consume souls to
keep themselves sane but remember the
game you're playing this sounds a bit
too good to be true
the dialogue implies that people are
dreaming about drangleic without knowing
what it is so perhaps it's a trap
perhaps you're being drawn into
drangleic and perhaps this is why
there's so many souls there or perhaps
on going off on a tangent and making up
my own fanfiction but regardless we'll
see if I'm right in time so all we have
to do is wait the next line of dialogue
is as follows
long ago in a walled off land far to the
north a great king built a great Kingdom
I believe they called it drangleic
so if you watched my Dark Souls 2 lore
video from a few days ago
he would know that I'm certain that Dark
Souls 2 takes place in the future
respective to Dark Souls 1 so when the
narrator says long ago here she's
describing drangleic before it fell to
ruin but what ruins this Kingdom well we
have no hints about that at this stage
but I'm sure we'll find out once again
if we have a bit of patience there's
only two months left guys anyway the
last piece of dialogue from the narrator
is at the end of the video your wings
will burn in anguish time after time for
that is your fate the fate of the cursed
I feel like this is in reference to the
quote in the original game like a moth
drawn towards a flame your wings will
burn in anguish just like the undead a
reborn at the bonfire after going
through death so too are moths drawn
towards their own agonizing deaths it's
a brilliant metaphor for the fate of the
cursed so overall this opening scene
tells us a bit more than you'd expect at
first glance and same goes for the rest
of it so let's move on to a sort of
quickfire round where I tell you a few
things I gleaned from these screenshots
katanas confirmed hard leather set
returns Faris's hat looks awesome this
dude is creepy as [ __ ]
bandit set new double bladed spear
weapon Eagles confirmed claws confirmed
new bosses a giant flame look at esque
demon an ancient wooden giant who looks
really pissed off the cutscene with
spiders a boss made of people picking
something up with his people clans and
to close up of these dragons that look
awfully like the dragon transformations
in the dragon covenant perhaps this is
the next stage of their evolution it'd
be pretty cool if true and last of all
dialogue that you can barely hear over
the music there are few things said that
I can barely make out and here's the
first so let me know if you hear the
same thing
what do you think he said I have two
interpretations the first is the Mad
King will never be forgiven foolish
human we know that there's a king in
Dark Souls 2 and he seems to be coming
up more and more as we learn more
tidbits about the game and I'm certain
he'll play a big role my second
interpretation of the dialogue is this
humanity will never be forgiven or maybe
the mad will never be forgiven by the
way this seems to refer to humans and
how they made some huge mistake that led
to them being condemned maybe an event
in the first game or perhaps the thing
that was responsible for humanity being
cursed so let me know what you think in
the comment section right below that
like button another line of dialogue
comes later where a voice actor who
sounds like Ingrid says this you need
the abyss the abyss seems to be born
from corrupted humanity or humanity that
has gone wild but why do we need it
again there's a few ways to interpret
this maybe he's saying that the abyss
truly does represent some true age of
man just like Qarth told you in the
first game or perhaps he's referring to
how there needs to be some balance
between light and dark for Humanity to
go on once again you decide let me know
what he think down below so capping off
this cursed trailer segment there's one
thing in the trailer that you might have
missed it's this a t14 rating as opposed
to M for Mature now that's interesting
I mean t14 content is suitable for ages
13 and up containing violence suggestive
themes crude humor and minimal blood
mature is 4:17 end up containing intense
violence and blood and gore now I don't
think they're turning down dark souls 2
so this is kind of strange to me I mean
some of the things in the trailers is
much more horror esque than before I
mean torture implements up a boss who
has people four hands I'm surprised they
pushed it down to a t rating but I don't
think they're attempting to fit it into
one so anyway let's move on to the next
topic already in this short but
satisfying article edge magazine states
the Dark Souls 2 will be harder than
what we all experienced in the beta I'll
talk more about this in my PvE analysis
video but one thing I did notice was
that everyone myself included did have a
fairly easy time defeating two bosses
and and
area in only a few hours I also note
that the mechanics and gameplay in Dark
Souls 2 is solid it's all there and at
this stage and development from software
is just tweaking you know changing
damages balancing stats little changes
that will make a huge difference in
regards to difficulty though
in the most recent beta there was
actually a point where a hard mode was
activated when enemies did double damage
and let me tell you all of a sudden
there were a hell of a lot more
bloodstains people were dropping left
and right and myself included it goes to
show that they can change the difficulty
with the flip of the switch so we just
flat-out shouldn't make judgments on the
difficulty based on what we've seen just
have faith and from software our lords
and saviors and my last piece of news is
going to be the gift that keeps on
giving because a little while ago Namco
Bandai announced on their Facebook page
the Dark Souls 2 will be getting its own
official comic book release and release
of this comic book has already started
so every week two pages of the
publication will be released the first
five pages have already been released
and they're intriguing for anyone who's
even moderately into the law the art
style is gorgeous as well so I recommend
you go check it out and keep a tab on it
I'll have a bunch of links in the
description from everything in this
video that you should just click and
click and click until you keep yourself
entertained for the next few hours so
just open them all in new tabs and enjoy
cheese guys I hope you're enjoying the
regular videos follow me on twitter at
VAR d video for updates and make sure
you leave a like if you'd like to see
more 2014 is gonna be such a huge year I
promise so make sure you're all
subscribed so you can enjoy the journey
to and through Dark Souls 2 with me I'll
see you in the next one if you learn
something new in this video leave a like
if you get 5 out of 5 and know
everything well done and feel free to
leave a dislike don't feel guilty I can
take it alright let's do it
number one I'll start us off with
something you might have already learned
from my video